this is the year of the hundred and
fiftieth anniversary of 14th amendment
the least of its passage the mass murder
and Charles can happen and nothing was
over now what we don't want to happen is
that it takes something like that again
to get Americans thinking about the
anniversaries of reconstruction with
reconstruction we're gonna have to force
it because most Americans don't think
about reconstruction or for that matter
even know anything about it why do we
have law why on earth did we even have
government why do we have this deep
abiding eternal problem of federalism
and states rights why do we have this
deep abiding and probably eternal
problem of race both of those huge huge
American dilemmas pass right through
this story of how we got three
constitutional amendments and the
re-imagination of the US Constitution
out of our Civil War what I've asked our
panel to do is just to just declare
their own sense from their own tradition
their own work of the most significant
powerful legacy or meaning of the
Fourteenth Amendment we've talked about
process limitations we've talked about
the end of one kind of power the
beginning of another kind of into one
regime beginning of another shining in
the Sun moment the great rise and
seemingly rapid fall why couldn't the
14th amendment hold these great ideas
within 10-15 years of its passage
it's being eroded how could this great
revolution rise so fast and then fall so
fast that's a great question but you
know even as I said even the 14
amendment itself has weaknesses within
it commas not it's compromised it is not
what the Radical Republicans wanted nor
was the 15th amendment written in the
way the Radical Republicans wanted the
old concepts whether it's racism or
localism federalism were still and very
much alive as they are today do you
think the 14th amendment could be
ratified today no it is possible to do
things in a revolutionary crisis whether
it's the end of the crisis or not as
John said that in normal times are
almost impossible to do and I think as
normality came back in some ways the
older attitudes began to reassert
themselves pretty quickly the court is
already chipping away rather strongly of
what the 14th amendment is all about so
um you know what you could turn it
around and say how did they ever manage
to get this thing passed
now you know that could be the
remarkable thing rather than the fact
that it couldn't really be implemented
fully over a long period of time you
could see the 14th amendment almost as a
proposed peace treaty this is the end of
the Civil War here's what the server and
they did say if the southern states
ratify they're back in and Tennessee did
ratify and has got its representation
back the rest of the southern states
just as stupid after the war as before
said now forget that now they'll never
do anything more so we're going to
repudiate we're gonna refuse to ratify
but in a sense it's a proposed peace
treaty to end the war and have a have a
post-war regime but it that's not how it
works out because the South refuses to
accept it and you have to then go
further well the answer to David's
question would be that the 14th
amendment contains within itself and
it's move away from the seeds of the
story
mmm because in salary Nathan Bedford
Forrest is creating the clan just as the
beginning of the 40-minute process is
underway in South Carolina in 1870
there's gonna be all out in the Colfax
massacre of 1873 the same and the power
the power that can deal with continued
warfare the primary achievement of
reconstruction is federal supremacy it
is a revolution in the political
structure of this country with federal
authority promised to displace state
power when state power burdens people
who had been emancipated okay so it's
federal supremacy and section one backed
up by section 5 of the Fourteenth
Amendment which gives Congress the power
to enforce the amendment through
appropriate legislation what is really
being asked here is for the federal
government to be a perpetual censor on
state legislation and that just cannot
be and if you think about all of the
moments when the reconstruction project
have seen a decline whether it's in
section five or in even in the context
of school desegregation is all about
states rights that was the pushback
against the Civil Rights Act in 1964
what are you doing to the states how can
you take away state power so that's
federalism in a word is what I would say
I think the real question is the inverse
and how did something so radical ever
even happen for a brief shining moment
so America's Constitution is built on
slavery the electoral college is
designed to give the South basically a
big insight advantage for the presidency
because they get to count slaves I'll be
in a three
discount 32 of the first 36 years it's a
white slaveholding Virginian in power
Pennsylvania has more free people than
Virginian 1800 way more voters than
Virginia and fewer electoral votes you
take away the extra electoral votes that
Thomas Jefferson gets from slavery in
1880 means that election the states that
get rid of slavery even say if they
didn't have very much slavery got rid of
it very slowly it takes Connecticut 50
years New Jersey 50 years you know
because their entire way of life
depended on foreign oil
I mean dependent on slavery and they
couldn't easily transition away from it
their economy did and the north is
complicit in this with shipping and
insurance and banking everyone's
profiting from it's the engine that
drives America so Abraham Lincoln says
1858 is going to take us a hundred years
at the least to actually get put us on
because he proposes but he's they've run
a path of gradual abolition slave
emancipation gave rise to a new
conception a free personhood that all
human beings possess a fundamental right
to seek amusement and to experience
rapture in public by virtue simply of
being human in the era of reconstruction
the sovereignty of the American nation
state became tethered to a new birth of
a right to be an amusement seeker as
embodied in the 1875 Civil Rights Act
here was something new in the history of
human rights a guarantee of non
acquisitive happiness as the negation of
chattel slavery consider an appeal
uttered by a Freeborn black man who'd
once been an operator of the Underground
Railroad and with LED color troops
during the Civil War he spoke of viewing
The Merchant of Venice attesting to
quote rights and feelings that
distinguished him from a brute in
appreciating works of art quote I feel
keen
he said quote Shylock's words to pick
the feelings that animate with great
intensity the colored man I'm not
demanding a pound of human flesh but I
am demanding exact justice as
denominated in the bond between me and
my government end quote
listen to a letter from Virginia
ex-slave to true Senator Charles Sumner
he wrote quote look at the white man and
the black man they both have one bone
one blood if I pay my money at a place
of public entertainment it is as good as
if a white man had paid his at the same
place all that are sacred will be found
in one heaven end quote
consider the argument of Senator Charles
Sumner the author of the 1875 Act
justified the authority of Congress to
enact the law under the Reconstruction
Amendments quote the Constitution is
over running with power it must be
interpreted to advance human rights
thus Congress must protect his pursuit
of amusement as an inviolate right of
freedom when you think about the facts
on the ground how in a society that that
was imbued with white supremacy lots of
different people were implicated in
undermining Friedman's rights and so the
impulse there makes sense but in the
final analysis the Supreme Court is is
is deeply involved in restricting the
interpretation of the Reconstruction
Amendments I wanted to go back to the
point about section 5 section 5 of the
Fourteenth Amendment makes
reconstruction and ongoing projects
allowing Congress to respond to problems
of inequality not only of race but of
gender all sorts of discriminations
disability and so forth and over time
pursuant to section 5 Authority Congress
has
a whole range of legislation that makes
reconstruction a project that has been
live and important for all of us so the
Fair Housing Act section 1983 of the
Family and Medical Leave Act the
Violence Against Women Act all sorts of
laws that not only implicate racial
inequality not only implicate the
original meaning if we want to go to
that point of reconstruction but all
Americans bringing all Americans into
the reconstruction project the second
reconstruction during the era of the
1960's is a do-over
successful in part because new voices
are a part of the discussion of the
meaning of the Constitution I'm talking
about the social movement actors dr.
King who has the ear of President
Johnson they're all apart all of the all
of these actors are part of the context
in which Congress enacts the omnibus
Civil Rights Act of 1964 which is a
do-over of the 1875 Civil Rights Act the
anti-discrimination norms of
reconstruction also are part of the
logic of a Supreme Court upholding that
Civil Rights Act and so in the final
analysis the reconstruction history the
reconstruction legislation the
reconstruction vision lives on against
new life during that era even if at the
Supreme Court it's understood in terms
of a commerce clause I had a question
about enforcement and the 14th amendment
professor Foner you mentioned that there
is much more debate over the third
section of the 14th amendment in the
first I'd love to hear a little bit
about how much debate there was over the
fifth section of
amendment you know the problem is it's
difficult for Congress to enforce you
know things in going on in the states
right I think the you know the question
is ultimately they they understood
enforcement has to be at the state level
the states are supposed to abide by this
I mean something that is so obvious we
may forget it when you put an amendment
into the Constitution you assume people
of you knew abide by it right that's the
law you don't assume you're gonna have
massive resistance to the law but
ultimate that's why the third section is
basically meant to help create new
governments in the south you don't have
a huge Justice Department's I even crate
until 1870 you don't have even today a
federal election officials being able to
sort of monitor every precinct look at
Florida in 2000 so there's very little
bureaucratic capacity and not only did
the southern states feel that this was
jammed down their throat so they don't
have a buy-in the Democratic Party has
no Buy in either it was jams down it so
every single member of the Conservative
Party in Congress votes against this
this was hatched the 14th amendment in a
Republican Party caucus in a secret way
it's a hyper partisan measure start to
finish so South hasn't bought in and the
Democratic Party hasn't bought in and
the former white Confederacy in a day
they are still they have not reconciled
themselves to that so so um democracy
works best when there's a buy-in when
the losers admit that they lost there is
a need for new legislation do we do you
think today with movements such as the
black vote black lives matter movement
there's still a need to grow the
legislation or just enforce these two
acts better that's a great question you
know so the question is whether today
with new movements like black lives
matter
are there enough laws on the books to
address their concerns or must there be
new legislation and what I would say is
you know I think it would be fabulous if
the laws that already protects that is
against excessive police use of force
our our were implemented I also think
that there's some utility in new
legislation but I don't necessarily
think that it's needed this is a problem
of law on the ground in law being in the
hands of officers who have you know
tremendous discretion it's it's really
not a situation for the most part I
think where there needs to be some
positive legislation it's it's it's
really an issue of human rights and
buy-in to the norms that already exist
the second reconstruction as the civil
rights era is often called needed was to
just enforce what the Constitution we
actually have and have had since
reconstruction and it's probably the
case now that there are plenty of laws
on the books about equal treatment
before the law and police brutality and
all that kind of stuff but they they're
not being enforced if new laws might not
be enforced very well either you know
that's the problem
Gandhi was once asked we do have a lot I
think a lot of good laws already on the
books Gandhi was once asked what he
thought about Western civilization and
he paused and he said he thought it
would be a good idea so all of you are
very distinguished historians whose job
is to examine history and not
necessarily predict the future but
obviously as we mark the hundred and
fiftieth anniversary of ratification of
the 14th amendment its legacy and the
fight over it lives on and you brought
up Shelby County the Supreme Court case
and voter suppression as it's happening
right now there are a lot of things that
are affecting you know millions of
people right now that are all tied up
and I'm wondering given your incredible
insights into American politics in
American history and American
constitutional law what is the most
effective way of you know really
reclaiming what the actual intent of the
14th amendment was and making sure that
people can vote and doing that kind of
stuff
so what is the most effective way of
moving forward and affecting real change
in the future so this is a way of
understanding the gay rights movement
and the incredible success over a very
short period of time it's people who are
mobilised who draw on the the civil
rights movements and what it's taught
and who demand full participation full
citizenship that's that's that's people
on the ground but even if it were going
on a question also it's where you go
back to Citizens United
as long as right I mean if you want to
get into this functional political
system that's dominated by corporate
money right if you have the right how
free is the on mobilization Martin King
mobilized but he actually mobilized
claiming the text he actually said there
were promises made in this document and
he wouldn't have been able to give that
same speech in South Africa at that time
because the South African government
didn't make those promises in its
constitution his Constitution actually
said the basis of our system is racial
separation and the basis of this one is
actually equality of many sorts it
doesn't even limit itself to equality so
actually if you're going to mobilize I
think this is a is a a rallying point
for mobilization and you should claim
your history all of it including the
history of reconstruction and the
progressive amendments because actually
the other folks on the other side claim
the Constitution the problem is they
haven't read it and they don't know its
history it's actually a radical document
for its time in 1787 and all the
amendments with exception of prohibition
of basically which didn't work
added to Liberty inequality and it's
actually it should you know it's like
what Gandhi said about Western
civilization you know it's a good it
sounds like a good idea the stuff in
here this already in here is pretty good
and is a bit and because this history is
actually correct in a way that the
Dunning school history actually isn't
and and that is power to actually have
the history of the 13th 14th and 15th
amendments on our side